gingrich is the former speaker of the
house he's a very smart man and we
thought we'd invite him on tonight and
ask him what is going on here why did
biden pick the most divisive policies
up front mr speaker thanks for coming on
tonight what do you think we're watching
here what's going on
well you know it occurred to me that
biden had lived through two
democratic disasters uh when clinton was
elected
two years later they lost 54 seats and
we became
a majority for the first time in 40
years when obama was elected
two years later they lost 63 seats
and i think what they've done is a very
uh
calculating and i think cynical ploy
which is they've given up on keeping the
house what they're doing is ramming
through
everything they can get done before they
lose in 2022.
so this is kind of a sprint to
radicalism
even though it's going to cost if you
look at these votes in the house you've
got 30 40 50 members
who are not going to be able to go home
and defend them they're not going to be
able to explain it
and i think that the biden harris model
is we're going to lose the house anyway
we might as well grab everything we can
while we got the power
and it's it's it's astonishing just take
the 1.9 trillion dollar political pork
bill
which is not a covet bill only nine
percent of its coven the other
91 percent is just political pork that
bill has
more radicalism in it than the eight
years of clinton
and the eight years of obama combined
just that one bill
and you're going to see wave after wave
i i describe it as a flood tide
of radicalism i i gotta wonder though
and i your analysis makes total sense
and and you've
i mean you know you ran the house so you
know how it works
but i just wonder the motive behind the
things that they want you said they want
to get the stuff they they want up front
makes total sense
but all the things that they want hurt
the country in measurable ways
we're energy independent they want us
not to be
they want to totally destroy our control
over the border they're letting foreign
nationals
roam the country unimpeded with kovid
like why would you want those things
yeah i mean i just did a tweet this
afternoon saying if there's a problem
with covet in texas
it's not governor abbott it's biden's
illegals
and we don't need we just have to call
them these are biden's illegals
coming in the country no public health
check i mean even back in the 1880s
we had public health checks oh yeah if
you came to america
but but here's tucker i really admire
your show
i really think you're remarkably
trenchant in your insights
but i just want to offer you a thought
they don't want to protect your america
they want to create an alternative
america it's an america
of of racial uh deep
inequality in an anti-white and by the
way anti-asian basis
it's an america in which transgender
dominates christianity
and judaism it's an america in which
they want to actually pass a bill
to create a permanent machine just like
california chicago new york
and that's not so when you and i talk
about why would they do this for america
it's because they really want
a radically different country and they
realize they disapprove of dr
seuss they really despise america
man that's not democracy as we've
defined it at all
and i appreciate your analysis speaker
gingrich thank you